[Music]
if the audition on America's Got Talent
that I'll certainly never forget and
lucky for us the man who stole America's
hearts with his talent is here with us
today mr. Cody Lee and his lovely mother
Tina thank you guys so much for being
here
[Applause]
it is a pleasure to meet you Cody I am
such a huge fan of yours after watching
that audition and I think you went over
a lot of people not just the judges
because I checked and your audition has
over 25 million views on YouTube
how crazy is that it's amazing not that
many people have watched you sing how
does it make you feel I feel excited
yeah I could tell well how exciting was
it for you to be on that stage and sing
for the judges it was so awesome were
you nervous at all no I'm happy now
happy nervous is a good nervous yeah I
couldn't tell if you were nervous mom
were you nervous for always oh I bet he
does not show the nervousness no no he
was meant to be on stage
Cody how much do you love singing I love
singing you're really good at it do you
know that really good in fact you're so
good at singing that you got Gabrielle
unions golden buzzer oh my gosh did you
expect to get the golden buzzer it was
an amazing moment especially because you
know obviously Gabrielle was so moved by
your performance what was it like for
you mom and for the family really to see
Cody get that kind of reaction from the
judges all
so the golden buzzer well first shocked
I mean even though you know even though
we know like his talent is just amazing
still you know you run into a lot of
things and you know like a lotta you
know during his whole life of the music
you run into a lot of I don't know if
it's called stigma or whatever it's
called but you run into where a lot of
people when you say yeah he's autistic
and blind and then you know they kind of
have that face like oh okay you know
like singing right but then he would
blow them away
so it was really shocking for us because
it was nice to see you know the the
judges just fall in love with him and to
really see his talent right like through
all of the disability not even seeing
any of that but to really see how
talented he really is like at the end
the day he moved on because he sings so
yeah oh yeah right oh yeah I mean that's
what's so that's what I think is so
amazing about AGT rise that it is a show
for everybody it's so inclusive it
doesn't matter what you look like what
your story is it gives everybody kind of
an equal chance what does it mean to you
to to know that Cody now has this
platform this outlet and that he's
inspiring so many people you know I'm
first of all really proud of him for all
his hard work like he's worked so hard
to get here and he's just yeah he's just
we've always had this goal we've had
this goal because when he saw a concert
years ago with Billy Joel and Elton John
face off oh wow he could hear the crowd
you know in that the whole theater you
know just the way the acoustics was work
yeah and I asked him I'm like ice I bend
over and I go hey Cody I go do you want
to be do you want to tune pianos or do
you want to sing for thousands of people
what'd you say I want to perform
thousands of people so we didn't know
we're gonna end up performing for
millions of people millions of people
but you were ready for it weren't you
Kony thank you me like as his mom I was
like looking for that thousands of
people so I thought that's gonna be my
goal as
and we exceeded that you really did I
really really did like I said over 25
million people just on YouTube alone
right touching hearts truly it's a lot
that's a big number with a lot of love
like a lot of love so tell me more about
that concert Cody you loved Elton John
and Billy Joel and that kind of it what
inspired you to want to sing and play
piano and perform for millions of people
yeah that sound like he was so found
it's a good feeling
it's a good feeling thank you yeah
when did you realize that he could play
piano or that he wanted to German
lessons did he say oh I went after Billy
Joel and Elton John did the battle I
want I want to do that when I hit the
keys now he was 2 years old
daddy just like played like mierqis
neither one of us are musically inclined
at all we don't have any nothing to give
you guys we don't know we don't know it
starts with him and both of our other
kids can sing beautifully they all have
beautiful voices but him he just reached
over and copied and that's when we
realized oh my gosh so we kept like
doing like little little little whatever
we were doing but he copied us you're
like a plain old buttons here we were
acting like the piano players but you
just play he would play everything we
did and he wasn't even looking he was
just reaching over and when a family
donated a piano at age three he just sat
at there he's super excited he just you
know sat there and he lists he literally
everything he heard on the radio he he
just played the course to like
everything on the radio I bet you're
right hasn't even he's still impressive
every day every day every day oh my god
Cody does your brother and sister do
they sing with you while you play the
piano
thank you yeah what's it like to uh
share your love of music with your
brother and sister do you like it is it
your favorite like what's it like
playing with your brother and sister
yeah they were so excited for you when
you got that golden buzzer they ran out
there so did your dad
yeah it must be so nice to share this
experience has a family hunting it is
really it's because we're a good team
like we worked really hard as a team you
know to help him you know so just to
accomplish this look at that you get it
do it and you're still doing it like I
said this is just the beginning and as I
mentioned you know Gabrielle and Julian
in particular were so moved by the
performance did you guys get to share a
moment with them backstage at all um we
backstage we did we hugged and then I'm
trying to remember because it was so
well no no it was just the shock that's
still like even remember like even
watching it like when it came out I
didn't even remember I said half the
things I said because we were all in
shock like we were just blown away it
was one of those those those memories
that you'll never forget I can't even
imagine what is the one thing you'll
remember about that day the one thing I
remember was like tripped on a speaker
right when you're so nervous that is one
well the one big thing I remember is
when Terry Crews said Cody how does it
feel to win the golden buzzer and what
did you say I feel exactly remember he
said he says Cody he goes what's it feel
like to win to win the golden buzzer and
would you say do you remember what you
said
congratulations and I thought that was
the best thing ever because that shows
who he is like even though you know he
he won he still is like to the world you
know it's almost like a congratulations
you know to everyone because he's just
so loving right that he loves to share
everything it's not all just you know
about him yeah we should say thank you
honestly because it reminded me when I
was watching it just how powerful music
is in particular you know it really does
unite all of us I mean ever it made me
want to go listen to Donny Hathaway yeah
you know it made me want to listen to
more of you and play your video on over
and over and over I mean it was that
powerful
you know it's like it's kind of nice
cheering on someone like you Cody
because we want you to go far we really
really do in fact while you're on this
whole journey with a GT is there anyone
you're dying to me anyone famous you you
loved me who your favorite singers like
Stevie Wonder yes oh my gosh
have you seen Stevie Wonder play live
thank you Stevie Wonder anybody else I
like Ray Chow yep all the greats all the
greats right Tina what do you hope
people take away from Cody's story who
watch this to never give up you know to
keep trying especially like for the moms
I mean it hits home to me for the moms
with kids with special needs I just want
them to know that it's a lot of hard
work but if you if you keep going and
you keep on helping them and you just
work through it no matter how many times
you want to give up because I was there
I've been there many times I've wanted
to give up because there's another side
of him you know not just the music side
there's the side that we had to help him
you know we had to figure out a way to
have the autism coexist with his music
talent right it's not he had it was born
with it but he still had to work through
absolutely all of those emotions and
dealing with the world and I would tell
them that just to please you know keep
keep trying and find what they love to
do and try to you know encourage it and
support it and support it yeah and to
help use it too because I realized that
like his talent I used it to help him it
was kind of like you know you raise a
child you have you have a you know how
you you know when you raise them you
have to like say you you know you find
whatever they like or whatever they
don't
it's the same thing you uplift them you
come yeah give them the tools to follow
their dreams
exactly and you do the same exact thing
absolutely it's just hard a little
harder because you have to figure out
how to help them deal with the emotions
mmm what's amazing is between the autism
now music I mean it truly is a
superpower you know right oh yeah and we
can't wait to watch you sort Kody
congratulations thank you no thank you
you're amazing I can't wait to see what
else you're gonna perform on America's
Got Talent
all right it was very nice to meet you
and thank you so much for being there
both of these
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]